how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
with the falcon and the winter soldier
series over
the next marvel disney plus series that
we have to look forward to
is the loki series now unfortunately we
do have a little bit of a break between
the falcon and the winter soldier and
loki as loki comes out on june 11th so
we have about a month and a half until
the premiere
however we still have plenty to talk
about about the upcoming mysterious loki
show
we know a little bit about the show
already thanks to a teaser trailer and
the official trailer that marvel studios
put out about three weeks ago
but today we learn a little bit more
about the official plot
for the loki series thanks to some
official marvel legends merchandise that
came out that actually talks about the
plot and it actually reveals something
about the main
mcu timeline that could explain why
everything is going to chaos
in the loki show and not to mention how
critical the events of the loki show are
going to be for the future
of the marvel cinematic universe so
let's dive into it and break it down but
first if you're new be sure to subscribe
and hit the notification bell so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos and my captain america shield
giveaway ends this friday so be sure to
check out the giveaway details in the
description down below
so as i mentioned a new marvel legends
figure for tom hiddleston's loki was
officially revealed and as we can see
here he is wearing his tva
uniform he has his jacket on he has his
shirt and tie he has the brown pants and
he has a belt buckle that actually says
tva on it so he is actually working for
the tva like they talked about in the
last trailer that we got but more on
that in just a bit
side note it comes with red wing because
the build a figure offered in this
marvel legends package is for captain
america
sam's captain america with his wings so
red wing is irrelevant to loki but what
is super
relevant is what is said on the back of
the box not only do we get a better look
at loki on the back of the box but they
offer a description of the show
and it reads as follows mere moments
after his escape during the events of
avengers endgame
loki is apprehended by the time variance
authority
tba and arrested for his crimes against
the sacred
timeline now of course we knew the first
part but that second part about the
sacred timeline we didn't know
this reveals that our timeline the main
mcu timeline that we've known
all these years is a very very important
timeline and most likely the main or
prime
timeline of the whole entire universe
not just our universe but
all of the universes all of the
different variations all of the
different realities
ours is the main one and if we actually
connect this with what we learned from
the loki trailer things start to kind of
make sense in the loki trailer owen
wilson's character mobius actually
explains what loki did and how it
affected everything
we protect the proper flow of time
you picked up the tesseract breaking
reality
i want you to help us fix it
now in this scene he doesn't straight up
say loki you messed up the
main prime sacred timeline but now that
we know that it
is indeed the sacred timeline we can
actually start to connect some dots
in the scene on the screen they show the
main timeline
our main timeline from the events of
captain america captain marvel
iron man 1 all the way to avengers end
game and then they show
some branches breaking off of it this is
loki messing up the prime or
sacred timeline as it's referred to in
this plot description
because of what he did in avengers
in-game taking the tesseract and leaving
and it looks like this is going to have
some pretty big implications because
loki is actually kind of cooperating
with the tva
this is loki the god of mischief he
doesn't play by anybody else's rules but
his own
and while the tva i'm sure has some
pretty good tricks i'm sure loki could
manage to escape if he really really
wanted to
however i think that the tva
specifically owen wilson's character
mobius was able to explain how he
affected this sacred timeline and how
the implications of this
could be super catastrophic and although
loki is the god of mischief
if he's dead it doesn't really matter so
yes i'm sure the tva is somewhat forcing
him to work for them but loki is also
kind of going along with it
now of course this is definitely for his
own reasons discovering why this
timeline is so sacred and
discovering if there could actually be
other sacred timelines because if we
think about it for a second this would
actually
explain a few things that we've been
wondering about a lot of things happened
in avengers in-game and we know that
loki escaping with the tesseract isn't
really the only bad thing that happened
yes the avengers went back in time and
yes they did everything that they could
to make it seem like nothing happened
but there were a few slip ups so the
question is why
isn't the tva going after any of the
avengers well this could be because the
timelines that they messed up actually
weren't prime or
sacred timelines and the reason the tva
isn't going after them for
their own timeline is because everything
that they did was to actually
save their timeline or this sacred
timeline as it's referred to
however as we see in the trailer loki
clearly messes
a lot of things up in fact in one scene
we see that in a different timeline new
york city and the avengers tower as well
is in complete destruction it's
completely destroyed and this is
seemingly caused by loki
taking the tesseract and it's also worth
noting as i mentioned in my breakdown of
the loki trailer that loki
this specific loki that we're going to
be following through the loki series
isn't the main loki he's a variant of
the main loki which
could be our loki since they're talking
about our timeline being a sacred
timeline it would make sense that our
loki the one that died in avengers
infinity war
was actually the main and prime loki we
see this in the trailer where loki is
asked to sign
to verify an insanely huge stack of
paper is everything that he's ever said
at the very top left of the paper it
says variant
l which stands for loki one one three
zero so this is loki variant one
thousand
one hundred and thirty that's a lot of
loki's and we see some throughout the
trailer as loki goes through many
different timelines and we even see
lady loki who seems like she's actually
going to be one of the main antagonists
of the show
now another question that this clears up
is the question of
will the tva eventually go for the
avengers and the answer is
no this plot description for the loki
series says that he is captured just
mere moments after the events of
avengers in-game that means that he took
the tesseract
escaped and right after he escaped the
tva was waiting for him
that means if any of the avengers truly
did mess something up
the tva would already be there steve
rogers created a whole
different timeline one where he was
actually living in it and married to
peggy carter and the tva didn't go after
him
and that's because he really didn't do
any harm to the main timeline
the introduction of a sacred timeline or
a prime
timeline is a huge setup for the
multiverse
keep in mind that loki is happening
before the events of spiderman no way
home
and doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness two shows that are really going
to dive into the multiverse and it makes
sense that they are putting loki
first because in this series we're going
to really explore
what the multiverse actually is and
explore many
other different timelines and realities
but it is nice to know that at the heart
of everything
our mcu timeline that we've known since
the very first iron man movie
is actually the main timeline and it is
going to be pretty fun to see
the multiverse broken into pieces in
spider-man no way home and then
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness but also loki is going to have
some pretty serious implications for
other shows that are coming as well
specifically kang the conqueror
it's already been confirmed that ant-man
quantum mania is going to introduce the
villain kang
kang is the master of time travel and
it's heavily rumored that kang
is going to be making an appearance in
the loki series after all king does have
a pretty big connection to the tva and
the timekeepers which have been shown in
the loki trailer
so loki is going to be an insanely
important show and we only have to wait
about a month and a half until we see it
in the meantime be sure to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
loki videos and of course
other marvel videos as well and let me
know what you think about this new plot
detail
in the comments down below don't forget
to like the video and for live updates
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you